as we come out of lockdown it's worth
just asking the question how is the
economy
doing and we had some data on that from
the office for national statistics it's
about gdp basically
the total amount of money that we're
generating across the economy and you
can see the level of it
here so it went down around the point of
financial crisis back in 2008
up and then you can probably spot work
over at 19 have an enormous fall
there and the good news is uh the latest
data and that's for february shows
there was no point four percent growth
in february uh and if you put that in
the previous months together a little
bit better than expected
um but still just look at the gap
between where we are now or at least in
february
and that pre-covered level so that the
zero line there is is where we were
before covert struck 7.8 percent in
terms of that gap
at the moment and just put that in kind
of monetary terms you're talking about
164 million pounds or getting on towards
6 000 pounds
per household but the good news is we
are heading in the right direction so
the latest forecasts from the obr they
do the forecast for the government
so it kind of getting higher and higher
so that we do get back to that point
uh around the middle of next year so
back to pre-covert levels so that's good
news
but here's the thing it's not just about
getting back to where we were before
covered struck it's about
getting back to that trend you know the
economy was growing back then it's about
trying to regain all of that lost growth
and look that's the pre-covered trend
and if we just zoom in a little bit you
can see
there is a bit of a gap there and what
the obr is talking about involves some
permanent scarring in other words
permanently
foregone economic growth for all of us
it's not the first time that we've had
something like this potentially if we
just zoom out and look back at 2008 i
mentioned the financial crisis
a moment ago back then you can see
that the economy went down a bit it
doesn't look that big does it but look
at the trend
so if the trend had continued i'm going
to have to zoom out here so you can get
a good sense of it
if that trend had continued you know
we'd be about 30 bigger than we what
than we are
or at least we were before covert struck
um you'll be familiar with this
potentially talking about trend growth
talking about foregone growth a lot of
people talked about that when it came to
brexit
and one of the things that we've been
looking at recently is what's happening
to trade because that's one of the ways
that that feeds into growth
you'll remember that trade volumes fell
very sharply at the start of the year
we've got latest data through it shows
that those exports mostly did bounce
back
but imports over there they bounce back
quite a bit
less quickly we'll keep keep watching
that in the coming months as we get more
data on it